So interesting.
So, I'm wondering whether this,
if we have a C that is aspecific,
which is to say the probability that I
get it right if it's one kind of thing
versus the probability I get it right if
it's some other kind of thing, we can
probably generalize that C to having
a different C for each of the actions.
>> Yeah, we could.
I don't want to, but we could.
Actually, I think the more likely case
in some sense is a weird one that seems
counter-intuitive, which is not for
every action to have a different C.
But what's the probability that
I would say something is right,
versus the probability I
would say something is wrong?
Those don't have to be
the same probability.
This C actually represents the
probability that the label I give you is
correct, but
there are actually more possibilities.
There can be,
there's a difference between a false
positive and a false negative.
>> Got it
>> So,
we're treating it as if there's only two
cases here, but there's actually four.
>> Okay, that's fair.
>> But no one wants to do that.
So, the last thing I'll say about this
before I move on to my last slide is
notice that I've acted as if
there's only two cases here.
There's the case where any policy can be
optimal, and then, there's a case where
only one can be optimal, but
there's actually spaces in between here.
So, you could imagine a case where
you might say, well, there can
be more than one optimal policy but
it's more likely there's only one.
It's slightly less likely
that there are two.
It's slightly less likely that there
are three and so on and so forth.
And you can have a prior over any
of the combinations of actions
being optimal and
that prior need not be uniformed.
And in fact, even here,
we're actually assuming a distribution
over all the possible two to the N minus
one policies in such a way that each
action independently is equally likely.
You could set things up so that, yeah,
sure, it may be the case that there's
more than one optimal policy, but
A alone is much more likely than A and
B which is even more likely than A,
B, and C and so on and so forth.
>> Does that make things much
hairier in terms of the formulas?
>> Much hairier.
I mean the reason we end up with
something that's this simple over here,
and this simple in the general case, and
this simple in the only one case is that
we get to eliminate
all the common priors.
>> I see.
>> And if we can't eliminate it,
we gotta carry them around with us.
>> Neat.
>> Okay, cool.
>> Okay, that's cool.
Now, does this tell us what to do also
if we have a prior that some action is
correct, because, let's say, we've
been learning for a while like, yeah,
that really seems like
the right thing to do, and
then the human is telling
us something else.
Can we factor in the information that
we've gotten from our own experience?
>> That is exactly what I was going to
bring up next, so why don't I do that?
>> Awesome.